welcome to this video cool it cool it
also a new opponent not played in before
surprisingly it seems like I know the
handle okay Queens gambit our keys
playing this we should be for the Rogo's
and you are playing a very very
conservative lining and said I don't
know that opening to Elsa let's
transpose to the the NIMS oh here mmm
came night e-cig that's the old line a3
is the main line now but I think in
recent times white also played with
played this quite a bit the capture and
then aged 3 I never really thought that
this could be super great but White has
caught quite well with that so maybe ok
here's some he's intending to use the
spin immediately interesting so can I
somehow keep this pawn like night a for
this is very stupid maybe it is ok but
let's try this at least the threatens a
3 uh-huh so he stop minding to give up
the dark squared Bishop that's that's
good news so let's just let's just grab
this Bishop Pam um ok it's before here
possible or is Quincy 3 a big big issue
I have rugby one intending I'm telling
we should be too now okay Quincy three
looks I thought this looks silly
actually isn't it isn't it strange if i
go here should be two or threatens to
win the Queen yeah I can take with the
pawn yeah still I still I'm threatening
Bishop b2 and a half the total bishop
and isn't this good for what of course I
have this double porn and it was
slightly weakened from interesting and
slightly weakened kingside I was about
to say but this is a risky move if I go
F for here threatening rook be three
winning the Queen isn't this isn't this
may be an idea I can also play rugby
three Queenie 5f for but at four
immediately okay let's see how is how is
handling that and maybe he can play 94
actually 94 would be three Queen f6
queen d 5 and then some sort of tactic
hmm maybe well I should have thought
about that maybe otherwise I'm yeah okay
he's just he accepts that he must
retreat him okay but how am I going to
do this now we should be too i guess so
very very nice position now with the 22
bishops maybe
let's pile up on this diagonal make sure
also that I got this blockade set up
okay take the C file step by step and
Bishop d3 next okay Bishop d3 next to
place Queen g4 and makes a draw so this
is what we don't want we should f3 maybe
but then there is possibly night see for
coming okay look to you form this is
really a problem or interesting
hmm
maybe even have three years old f3 king
of to look you wan yeah okay the time
this would be very nice position to play
with some time on on the hand and tongue
on lands really trying to get the best
out of it because I think with precise
play widest sir very close to him to
winning actually the two bishops on an
open boards have blockade on deform and
the long diagonal that's a very very
nice position f3 is a bit ambitious but
I want to get control over g4i deform
yeah King f2 now he has Queen 83 not
very nice but maybe I can still do that
if he goes to age 3 I can't even go here
what's the big problem I have rook g1
Luke g3 coming and then I'm winning this
on the long diagonal
I think this looks looks tremendous we
just double him
okay now if you if he takes on h2 I mean
let it let it be it really should be far
too much far too much pressure on black
not threatening anything at the moment
because I'm in a self pin pull yeah as
mentioned with some time on the clock it
would be very nice but this this way
it's a tad shaky maybe I should play f5
next and if if we trade queens this
would be a would also be excellent
really the bishop on d4 protects III now
maybe maybe f5 is really an idea again
something like rock is six for example
f5 can be good he's not playing and not
hoping i hope i don't not disconnected
or anything no I'm not that's good it's
a price that is taking that long
understand that it's not an easy
position but still
she disconnected no hmm although we're
looking something very trivial not sure
yeah you never know maybe his door
better ring or anything that's a shame
if I win this game now on time I mean I
don't mind to win a game but i would
like to UM sort of conclude this game
really weird yeah it sometimes happens
it happened to me so many times yeah I
kind of have the pizza ordered or
something and the doorbell is ringing
and what what what do you do let the
pizza guy go away with your food no and
this is how you lose some game sometimes
no I don't know what it is black
forfeits on time jump no idea um yeah we
sort of can try to try to continue from
here it's funny yes night h5 which had
that didn't even consider this is the
computer serve choice giving wyd an edge
but nothing dramatic yum around here is
probably where my improvement should
come in this f3 was more I don't know
okay the computer gives King edge one
with white basically winning yeah plus 2
or 1.6 stockfish you know he gives
rookie rookie for yeah this is what I
was cause this is what I was worried
about of course but after this it really
does not help him in yeah this is much
better now I get to play on the G file
without the King being in any trouble as
such as much just much better yeah this
is a case where f3 was really ok I don't
want him to go nitey rupee for that's me
and
a g4 but this is just just not as good
simply not as good just just this is
excellent yeah the problem is that if if
black is some I don't know what black
should be doing I can give you the best
line that that the compound compass
having hear this and now I'm piling up
on the on the G file this is this is
really terrible I can also do this and
let's say something like this f5 look
somewhere and let's say here we get this
going and here black is close to being
in a zoosk long you cannot do anything
so terrible position yeah and after this
things get get very unclear rook rook
here yeah no I'm curious about the final
position I don't want ef5 was already
very strong yeah I saw this only only a
bit later it's basically forces the
Queen trade and this leads to a position
where white is an excellent change this
is like the the monster bishop on this
this central square and basically
unassailable cannot drive it away
fantastic position and TM I thought this
should be good as well but I really
didn't c 9 h 5 at all the compass giving
a king g to him still with the with a
good game as black of course cannot take
its eliminate I didn't see any of that
but King g2 makes lots of sense engine
wants to go here and gives white only a
slight advantage yeah it's clear that
compared to what I could have had with
King edge one I I really have firm I
have deteriorated my position what's
something like this is playable it's not
threatening anything really okay yeah so
a shame it would have been interesting
to see this game concluded and would
have been tricky with me being down more
than 1 minute 3 we know the deal
but now this was an interesting game I
thought that this really wasn't such a
great great idea that he gave up the
dark squared Bishop here this looks very
very logical and now he's in this Bishop
g2 business and form 94 I was briefly
worried about but I can really take it
that I can immediately take it yeah this
is of course make some sense ok so here
and now we get to the this this
excellent position in fact here the comp
gives you can see one that's even better
hmm and rooks e7 yeah it's just like
that in an in an open position to
bishops against two nights is very often
such a substantial advantage that it is
not to win the game if there's nothing
special happening like you're getting
mating or anything that it's really
something that should give you big edge
ok thanks for watching